DIY or more like di don't di die or DIY
why would you create that stop it get
some help
there seems to be a never-ending flow of
DIY channel these days so let's review
the finest of them let's look at the top
of the cream here we have a rumba the
early years so he's putting hot glue on
a screw and then he put some is that a
motor it is okay the screw now spins and
then more hot glue okay and that's on
Anna thanks JD that's funny action
that's really funny for a for everything
that was amazing I take it back this is
actually really good
coming over to someone's house oh it's
had one of those robot vacuums pit I got
me one of those a bowl of human
suffering okay alright I'm into it five
minutes craft so they're putting a bunch
of Tim soldiers into a bowl and then
they bake it Oh God
oh wow it's a bowl of pain oh why would
you do that have you ever went to
someone's house and be like oh that's
cool and they're like oh I saw it's from
a DIY Channel I saw it and then I made
it the whole concept of these videos is
that they look fun to make but they're
ugly let's get real that's ugly you
wouldn't buy that no one would buy that
right you wouldn't buy that would you oh
don't know why did i extremely distress
by this mood-ring toilet seat I just saw
mood-ring toilet seat now that's a
product I would invest in what kind of
mood oh is your [ __ ] in oh it's
aggressive today imagine if you lived on
your own and even came home to find
evidence of a butt on your toilet and
the butt was angry Oh Lord you better
call the cops straight away if that ever
happens my god oh yeah see this is like
the prime uh he even adds the flavoring
dude
it blows my mind that this is something
that you can do I don't know if it makes
me angry or just it just makes me
emotionless it makes me what kind of
spray is that that seems like ceramic is
ceramic spray a thing why do I care I
don't know
there are ceramic spray okay cool
I'm so glad I'd know that okay my mom
tried to make a cane for my dad Wow
oh my god it's got a nail sticking out
of it I better come with a tetanus shot
Jesus Christ we don't need to buy a cane
I'll just make you one look I like how
they mix screws and nails to create this
monstrosity Jesus Christ
y'all I'm at my friend's house and I go
to use the bathroom and what is that oh
that's so I never understood that you do
that in America right I understand the
bus needs to be warm 100% understand
Japan has to figure out they have a
heated toilet seats I don't know why
whenever I come back to UK after a trip
down I always dread going to the
bathroom because it's like now my butt
is gonna be cold I hate it but this is
not the solution this is not the
solution don't DIY a warm heated seat
toilet oh wow that looks so good look
it's like a Sun and it's got the rainbow
in the background don't you feel more
lovely now don't you look more pretty
look how pretty you are in this god it's
ugly this is another five minute craft I
swear to God
okay so she's trying to wipe the top of
the shelves so she grabs a scissor and
tape I can't tell
is it real I can't tell Oh God
you topple and die you die this is for
when you want to die but your reflexes
are getting the better of you do they
know you can move the chairs what
hilarious what were they thinking I
don't know I really don't know what they
were thinking I don't think they were
thinking more five minutes Kraft please
this is so funny this is the most ghetto
SHhhh
I've ever seen what is she doing how
she's screwing on bottles okay
understand what is this the deaf
stranding outfit what it's this so that
it was so that she can float in the
water I thought she was trying to
illegally import what there through the
airport why would you do that you're
still swimming with t-shirt I can't
believe this
they I've never seen I've actually never
watched five-minute crafts I just heard
how bad it was they have sixty-two
million subscribers what the [ __ ] oh no
cool I feel really good about my
achievement looking at this but bro the
video is 11 minutes it's not even five
minute craft oh wait I've seen the one
where she she makes a spoon out of a
spoon look she makes a spoon out of a
spoon she made a spoon out of a spoon
Sexy's oh man ah
oh god dy dy
I thought DIY would be questioning why
you create something but it makes me
wonder why I was created okay it's a
Coca Cola Fanta and sprite dispenser how
did how did it work oh yeah that happens
all the time okay so the attacks are
battery to motor and what else is it all
right we got three motors going I'm
really curious how this is gonna make it
pour though so you have to screw it to a
new code imagine how bored you must be
to create something like this this I
realize this is for kids right because
kids think this is cool but any adult
will just be like get that thing out of
my
it's not the worst thing I've seen on
here so far at least serious life hacks
serious ones seriously use popcorn okay
and then what here we go another five
minute craft they got two bricks and
they know it's not bricks it's foam clay
and you put the clay on the phone what
are they gonna make I don't know it's a
melon great it's a strawberry why a
contact lens solution why and now it's
mixed together and now you have a
strawberry but why why five minutes
Kraft why why did you make this why why
why why why what I think I would love to
see a compilation of kids recreating
this because even the result here is is
bad it looks bad I'm curious when
someone that all this a tutorial what
that looks like cuz it's gotta be some
monstrosity fake Sun roof decal for your
car wow that looked get so good but why
look more expensive now in case you
watch the car from above it looks more
expensive personal ice-cream ball or or
or you could just take the lid off does
anyone like my pack Jesus Christ
actually I've seen I've seen one life
hack that's useful and it's it's how you
open those super laminated plastic
things with a hanger on the top because
you can just pull it from the hanger
that wasn't useful actually but 99% is
garbage that's how it is isn't it they
reel you in with like one concept that
works and you're like holy SH I never
thought of that but that's actually
helpful and then you try and find more
things because obviously they have to
know more things because they know one
thing and then it's like 99% microwave
microwave mailbox alright another five
minute crack or crafts so she went to
jail five tricks people have learned in
prison that
can lit candles how to make crack
cocaine you can inhale the fumes oh it
to make a knife is she's gonna break out
from prison to that that's that how she
know I should make it better
oh look how fine they neatly and finely
cut they did it I don't think they can't
vegetables with that I really need to
cut these vegetables main I've been in
jail for five years and I have not been
able to cut my vegetables if only there
was a way nobody lifehack youtubers
those are the thumbnail you're like what
is that I guess I have to click on that
because what is that just go ahead and
chop your hair off in a random place so
you can make a brush that is probably
much worse than any cheap brush that you
can find at a drugstore brushes they're
just so expensive oh I cut off my hair
okay we have Mona Lisa
but why I don't understand hoody for cat
supplies what cat one-shot cut cut done
yeah yeah that one I can respect what
the hell is this oh wow he can store the
phone in the pee pee hole
yes why would you do that see the slime
stuff I don't get are you [ __ ] well
you don't play with slime as adults do
you not understand you know those are
fake ear pods anyway alright so this guy
is going through the effort of putting
his toilet into another thing it's a
thing now but why super fun party life
hack oh okay so you grab all this stuff
from the hot glue is the recipe for
disaster put it on a coke okay put those
inside I imagine yes and then you get
some cigarettes okay and then when you
pull it out it's gonna let itself it's
that it what it is that's it wow thank
you
well you add sugar to coke how the
gelatin to cook and then it's disgusting
god this pisses me off I'm speechless
how stupid is this five kinks hair for
one to bear that can't grow one eyeliner
draw the line
is he gonna is this it's this guy no
he's not doing that you're not doing
that you are not gluing you're not
gluing that on your face you're he is
going that on his face this is an actual
tutorial he's put it you just glued hair
to your face dude well done
congrat
relations I want to die this is a
tick-tock
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa that's crazy
why pour your drink when you can do this
[Laughter]
who's pouring your drink it's just too
difficult man imagine being at a party
someone opens the candy be like stop you
could spill that everywhere hold up let
me just get my hot glue here we go all
right dinky blip blip blip you're
welcome bro you're welcome bro here you
go bro
enjoy your fresh beverage bro bro is
literally dead because they took so long
I don't like I don't know if I like
where this is going
razor blade kettle so we got some razor
blades combined with it's gonna use it
to boil water is that what this is going
it seems like a bad idea I swear these
are just getting watch time because I
just want to see what dump they come up
with that's the only reason I'm watching
this what is that is that a scissors an
automatic scissor
I mean maybe for like handicapped people
or something but that's good but see I
can appreciate the memes the DIY memes
that's what I like that's good this gets
the only one I up vote on this whole
subreddit non-electric hoverboard works
best down hill don't fall on this thing
non electric hoverboard hundred dollars
retro it's retro it says antique kids
and think it's worth more because it's
old how to waste a hundred dollars
that's always what I want to know why
you didn't spend it on old pet bottles
there's the hundred dollar bill okay are
you doing he's getting the blow torch
he's laminating it that was it
these are just made to piss you off
right they could've just use a dollar
for the memes
I can appreciate Liam Neeson Ilene's
come on that's beautiful
someone stole wallet okay
so therefore you should use a tampon as
a wallet I got it
kind of funny though come on
I find it acceptable why not just buy a
hammer we went through the extensive
effort to make a hammer
I wonder where five-minute crash draws
the line of what not to post because
surely they come up with a bunch of [ __ ]
that's like--that's if that's a terrible
idea we there's no possible way we could
use that we're not gonna actually post
that but it's like they just don't have
that filter they just post it anyway
sick of my parents never closing the
door so I made this I can honestly
respect that that is one of those issues
that I'm so annoyed with you know out of
all Smart Home availability why don't
they have a so they can call it the
worst why can't I go Alexa closed door
my life is so hard
she's not gonna poop in that you're not
oh you're you are you gonna do that
alright I'm done I'm done that's it no
more what did we learn today absolutely
nothing thank you for watching smash
like and subscribe for more useless
videos almost as useless as these DIYs
thank you for watching bye bye hey hey
for too long you have been farting in
the garden now you are entering a new
era where you shall craft diode
the hour of fart smells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne
whoopty is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
you